So this heap property is a really useful thing, it's going to turn out.
It's important to figure out how we can take a bunch of numbers
and make them satisfy the heap property.
Let's do that. Let's start figuring out how that will work.
First thing to notice is that any one-node tree satisfies the heap property
because it can't be bigger or smaller than the parent or the child
cause it doesn't have any parents or child.
That case is really easy, but now, so let's imagine that we've somehow managed to create two heaps
and we've like to join them together by adding another node and have it the heap property hold.
Both of these subtrees the heap property holds which means the smallest values in the entire heap
are sitting here at the top of the relative roots, but now we're adding a new node.
If this node is already smaller, then these two, then everything's fine but it might not be.
It might be that this is a large value.
Let's give an example. So what do we do at this point?
We need a heap property to hold everywhere for this to actually be a heap. So what can we do?
Well, so with respect to these three nodes, we're going to need to change something
to establish the heap property of this locally.
First thing we're going to do is we'll introduce some swapping around.
Which value can we swap to the top to move things in the direction of
more establishing the heap property?
Which of these values should be at the root here? Write the answer in the box.